à un mois des élections régionales
valérie pécresse s'est rendue dans
plusieurs villages des yvelines jeudi 13
mai accompagné de gérard larcher est lee
a dévoilé les grandes lignes de son
programme pour le milieu rural
nous voulons l'égalité pour le rural
l'égalité pour les habitants de tous ces
territoires pour que les habitants des
territoires ruraux et un meilleur accès
à la santé une meilleure sécurité
un meilleur accès aux commerces plus
d'emplois plus de transport parmi les
propositions de la candidate la
construction d'un nouveau lycée dans le
canton d'houdan bonnière valérie
pécresse propose aussi d'élargir
l'enseignement supérieur au sein des
lycées
notre objectif c'est que dans chaque
lycée rural il puisse y avoir des bts
des classes préparatoires des licences
professionnelles donc de des
possibilités de poursuite d'études
qu'ils soient offertes dans chaque lycée
rural d'île de france
un nouveau mandat que valérie pécresse
souhaite aussi axé sur le numérique
nous continuerons le programme un
ordinateur par lycéen et par enseignant
pour que tous nos lycées soit 100%
numérique
nous voulons que tous les villageois
fibres et ce sera le cas dans les
yvelines à la fin de l'année tous les
villages seront fibrées nous voulons
évidemment déployer la 5g partout donc
l'idée ce sera qu'on puisse travailler
télétravail et de son village créé son
entreprise dans son village
malgré ces changements en milieu rural
la candidate entend conserver l'identité
des villages nous allons mettre 50
millions d'euros sur la rénovation du
patrimoine dans le prochain mandat pour
continuer à rénover des dizaines
d'églises de l'avoir de ferme de maisons
des illustres qui font évidemment l'âme
de nos villes et de nos campagnes et
valérie pécresse fait que de pouvoir
d'achat des franciliens restent
inchangés sauvegarder l'identité village
tout ça ça se fera en préservant le
pouvoir d'achat des habitants de la très
grande couronne comment est-ce qu'on
préserve le pouvoir d'achat va d'abord
tout ce qu'on propose en le finançant
hausses d'impôts évidemment les
élections régionales auront lieu les 20
et 27 juin prochains